the Joe Rogan experience but there's
this everybody and then there's Wilder
does everybody everybody with power
you've ever seen and then there's Wilder
while there's powers like what is
happening like he's got super power yeah
like his techniques not phenomenal it's
just not you sometimes he throws from
the hip it's just like not just you it's
over here's the thing he's not like a
George Foreman or like these bigger
dudes he's he's floats around to 13 to
2:19 yeah like he's not a big dude not
even not even remotely big it's insane
it's insane when he hit Ortiz in the
forehead and just draw and that's not an
easy fight no or no monster no and it
showed no more Ortiz is winning in my
book
who's winning I'm doing and I got fury
Wilder in February you can't wait for
that and what do you think about
Saturday night what do you mean Oh with
Joshua pieces I'm up do you do I do
really I hate when people say you know
oh it's like a Buster Douglas situation
it's not because someone doesn't like
Mexicans
so yeah we're kidding folks yeah my
girls make some I yeah yeah I could make
some for god sake jeez Andy Ruiz has got
a shot he has a shot but because he was
also beat it's not fluke like Buster
Douglas Mike Tyson because any Ruiz is
winning most the fight before he even
knocked him out yeah not got knocked
down third but he was winning
he had more rounds went in the bank well
he got knocked down but then he got back
up and knocked Joshua now correct so he
was ahead on the scorecards too so and
then he just stopped them right but I
think it was the perfect storm for
anthing Joshua to lose the fight I think
Joshua knows what he's dealing with
remember that was a late replacement
he's supposed to fight big baby Miller
and also going in that camp he was
dealing with some personal issues which
everybody does but the other things he
gotten the rumor is his comers he got
knocked out and camp by a Philadelphia
heavyweight suppose the guard you know I
forget that he's a stud I definitely
heard the rumor from multiple different
sources that he got knocked out legit
source I heard guys know it seemed like
it there was another rumor that he had a
nervous breakdown in the locker room
that he knew he shouldn't been fired and
his dad was like no let's not go out
there so that's why see his dad arguing
with
that he heard yeah and here's what else
is interesting too is now they're doing
the rematch it's in Saudi Arabia they
they didn't have arena there they built
it for this seats 15,000 people put in
so crazy he's making seventy five
million dollars some [ __ ] like wow yeah
for this fight and it's I think it
they're they know what's going on
there's something going on because it's
away from everything like media is not
gonna be the Saudi Arabia so there's
like the pressure of the English crowds
not there so I they're trying to protect
the Golden Goose here in Saudi Arabia
what do you think he's the Golden Goose
here's what our thing I think if Andy
Ruiz knocks him out again he's he's
bigger golden gooses there is in the
world injuries you know how many [ __ ]
Mexicans are our bro I don't have to
tell you made to yourself there's a lot
of Mexicans man and the guys soft-spoken
he's a sweetheart
he's got fantastic hands I mean he's got
a fluidity to him that you rarely see in
the heavyweight division wears a lot of
heavy weights they're like big one punch
guys oh he's just like bobbin and Weavin
a different combination that people are
confused because if you've just
discovered a new reason then anthe and
Joshua fight he's not a finisher he's
not a knockout artist that was just that
fight is balls to the wall he just had
nothing to lose he was like playing with
house money but now he's a better pure
boxer than Joshua but Joshua I bet you
finishes him under 10 interesting yeah
well he definitely heard him in the
first fight he heard him first and then
threw caution to the wind and got
cracked yep because he underestimated
Andy's resolve and his ability to
recover Andy is inside that you know
close quarters now imagine what would
happen if instead of going crazy and
trying to stop them what if he just
boxes on the outside and keeps trying to
a shot yes yeah this is gonna do yeah
instead of going in like you did in the
first fight correct this is I think is
gonna he's gonna stay on the outside use
a jab
set him up he's gonna win rounds with
footwork in boxing and then a vent in
the jab and then eventually 6 7 8 Ruiz
can be way down on the car that guy [ __ ]
go for broke I think it's not coming
interesting who knows see who that's for
sure
I feel like Ruiz is gonna have
incredible confidence because he's going
into this fight knowing that he's able
to beat the heavyweight champ of the
world win the title and Charlie's got
[ __ ] Rolls Royce now ok he's going in
there with champ attitude you think yes
or is he going there down
two things I don't think so I think you
realize he can hang with the Jess he
knocked him out he won the title I think
he's a [ __ ] champ and I think he's
got more love and more respect than he's
ever had in his life I think he likes it
seems like he's having a good time I
think we see an even better Andy Ruiz I
think we see beaten up I don't know I
don't know if he beats him but I think
he's gonna be better I think I think
Josh was gonna be better too I think
both guys realized this is Joshua but
also Joshua loses this fight it's a guy
where does he go for a minute I don't
know man I don't know I mean look you
tell me you wouldn't want to see Joshua
Wilder oh I'll watch Joshua fury all
goddamn day
oh wow door knocks Joshua Cole I want to
see everything me too I wanna see it all
let me see everything I want to see all
of it I think Andi lost weight was Andi
way now I think he's down his speeds
trouble manhood his combinations she's
so fluid so stable forget about Joshua
though man I remember can't forget who
was a gold and he got dropped by
wladimir klitschko
member that kid came back and just beat
Dillion white his resume is insane oh
yeah I mean Olympic gold medalist you
know and probably the best body in the
history the division boys body
seriously especially when he fought when
he fought Ruiz he was a little thick I
think he's lost little blade himself I
think one of the things he's done is
he's gone less strength and conditioning
and more pure box he was so big he was
talking about that he said essentially
his word the way described it is I was
listening to this interview with him
some English gentleman and he was saying
that you think about it you have a
hundred percent of your energy if you
put 50% of it to strength conditioning
and 50% of it to boxing you're not going
to achieve the same amount if you put
100% to boxing something to that effect
yeah so the idea is he's doing less
roadwork he's doing more conditioning in
the gym and he's doing like heavy bags
minute smart yeah it's because if you
look at you know India's kind of
advantages over and be speed
combinations so you don't want just be
this big heavy bulk or also if you're
looking at future matchups Fury and
Wilder they're all lighter on the feet
yeah you know move better better cardio
so how much weight is he lost him this
is Joshua he said he's taken on a prison
workout mindset for this fight well his
career is on the line I think yeah
here's a thing - then it's same with
Karma Greg
Conner's careers on the line as well
against cowboy oh for sure yeah so when
you put these guys and your wish has
tricked fans into thinking he's lost
weight did that Bert Kreischer trick for
this picture he said for a crasher trick
first of all how dare you sure though no
no training video there's a video of him
hitting the shield and he misses and
catches his trainer on the chin get a
little wild
[ __ ] yeah he drops his trainer I would
be worried about anybody's you know he's
haven't seen the spotlight and that
money and there's the Rose Royce and he
might've been part in San Diego I'd be
worried about him I'd be worried about
him you know being like oh this is the
life
yeah that's possible you know but I
don't think so
I think I think he's a discipline guy I
think he just goes wild I mean just
can't be that discipline with that body
no no no he looks a certain way that
you're you're not gonna get away with
discipline doesn't come to the food well
it's not gonna win any best body contest
but he [ __ ] a lot of people up [ __ ] a
lot of people up I don't think he's
gonna have a trick Joshua this time
though I me the first time he tricked
them Joshua is probably looking at him
like I'm gonna [ __ ] this boy Josh was
like oh oh that's what you do
I've seen this in the millions of fights
I've had in Olympics yeah watch this
that's what I think is gonna happen now
Ferraris wins alright but you know I
just I just I don't see it man
[Applause]